hi
here i am again the natural learning
society what are we going to do with
this thing
one thing we could do is
that anyone who is involved in language
learning
at university in schools in language
schools wherever
please start protesting
if you are forced to learn from
uninteresting content if teachers come
in
and give you
photocopied
news articles that they've selected for
you
if they spend all kinds of time
on explaining points of grammar that you
can't understand and won't be able to
remember
if you are not learning in a natural way
stand up and say i don't want to learn
this way
i want to learn naturally because if i
learn naturally i'm going to learn
better i can learn faster i'm going to
enjoy it
so i think we should start getting some
protest movements going across all the
schools and campuses and elsewhere where
people are being
forced to try to learn and understand
grammatical and theoretical concepts
that the brain is not yet ready to deal
with
and and let me stress that again the
brain will figure out its own rules the
the grammar explanation can help
i'm not saying it doesn't help and and
uh
my uh approach in dealing with grammar
is to buy
simply the smallest
uh the smallest possible
uh grammar book and i occasionally leap
through it and and what i find is that
occasionally leaping through it i see
some things that that remind me of
aspects of the language that i have
already started to observe so that
through naturally absorbing the language
the brain is starting to observe things
but certain other things it doesn't
quite see yet and sometimes these things
have to be pointed out and so leafing
through a grammar book may help you to
notice things and in fact that's the
purpose of correcting we correct things
not because we think that by correcting
something let's say the learner has
written or said that immediately
the learner will then be able to say it
correctly that immediately the brain
will have adjusted and now say those
things correctly that's not how it works
but sometimes correcting something helps
make the learner more
observant and i get back to spitzer he
talked about the three key attitudes
that we need for learning success and
again he emphasized the importance of
input appropriate input meaningful input
he mentioned how the learn the brain is
constantly learning so we know these
things the brain is constantly learning
but the brain needs three things it
needs
a certain degree of alertness in general
and attentiveness to specific issues
that it has to identify because
sometimes they can just go by and they
aren't noticed the second thing is that
the more emotional connection there is
between the learner and the the
subject that they're learning the better
and of course the third thing is
motivation but if we deal with this
alertness a tentative attentiveness it
is certainly true that if you make a
mistake a few times and you're corrected
you start to get a little bit aware
more aware of that particular issue and
so then hopefully you will start to
notice
that structure those words
when you're listening and reading so
you'll say yeah i had trouble expressing
this concept or i used this structure
and it was wrong so let's try and focus
a little more on that particular word or
that particular concept
uh shows up in in my listening
which is hopefully enjoyable because you
selected it
so
the grammar explanations
have to be and the corrections have to
be more along the lines of helping you
to notice things not in the hope that
you will now learn this rule and
therefore get it right
and i should add that a lot of
again in the in the
interest of keeping things natural
and meaningful
we should object to
exercises and drills and we should say
no just give me interesting stories to
read and if you want i will write for
you and i will speak for you and when i
write and speak naturally which is
natural communication you can correct me
if you want not too often please
and this will help make me a little more
attentive to those issues that i'm
struggling with it'll just make certain
words and certain structures stickier in
the brain but the explanation itself is
not going to uh immediately correct me
so when you are confronted with
unnatural learning in your classroom
protest and say i don't want to learn
this way i want to learn the natural way
and i want to join the natural language
society thank you for listening bye for
now